what's up fellow geeks it's ineo and
today we have the unboxing of the live
live collectors edition thank you again
bandai namco for sending this to us it
is a remaster of the 1994 game and it's
coming to the switch so let's open this
up
first things first open up the zip it's
over here
and oh
nice okay so first things first we have
the live live nintendo switch game and
the fans that already know you guys will
be playing as eight different characters
in eight different timelines so this is
gonna be fun but let's see what else is
inside
all right
all right we have the strap
for the bag
so this is all all around honestly it's
it's a very handy a collectivistization
that you can use for your day to day and
if you're a huge fan of life alive
this thing works out for you
okay let's see what else we have which
there is huge box in here
okay let me just take it out
before we get into the box let's check
out the bag for a bit the inside is
padded at the bottom you can flip it up
if you want to have a bit more space and
there's also a pouch on the side for you
to keep other things so very spacious
and honestly very handy
right so let's open the main box up
so we're gonna open it up now
oh
look at that
okay it looks like we have
live live stickers so the eight
characters are down here and also them
in sprite form down here these are two
separate stickers
next up we have
what appears to be
yeah i've i have no idea what this thing
is so let's open this
oh
i think i know what this is
oh it's the board game
yeah okay so like the live alive
collector's edition comes with a board
game but everything is in japanese
so i'm gonna need to
take some time or find someone to
translate this for me but yeah
let's go through what's inside the box
well various tokens and live counters i
believe for the eight characters that
are found in the game
on here look at that
that is quality right there and these
also very thick and sturdy so the thing
is they aren't really skimping out on
quality when it comes to like the game
pieces
all right here i'm guessing is the game
map
so it's a4 size and it folds in very
easily so if you guys want to bring this
out to play with your friends once you
guys figure out the game
yeah it's very portable
you got various cubes
and the game pieces of each individual
character in their sprite form and these
things are these things are
made of wood i think yeah
they're all made of wood
and all really really nice to hold and
oh look at the origin oh it's cute so
you have the the front of the character
and you also have the back of the
character
so
yeah this is wow
these are really well made
so yeah obviously you got all eight
characters down here you guys will skin
part on that
um
don't need this
and then i'm guessing uh these are cards
so there are like three of these action
cards for each character so
wow this is really well thought out
so let's put all this back nicely and
let's move on to the rest of the box i
believe there's some more stuff inside
but i remember what
oh
okay cool
right so here's the ost book we have two
cds on here disc one and this two for
the ost and over here we have the art
book which seems to be attached directly
onto the album as well i don't think you
can take it out so we're gonna leave it
there but yeah so we have lyrics for
some of the songs
we have
concept art and character artwork for
all the different characters and npcs
you'll meet and play as in the game for
the different time periods and i'm not
gonna go through all them you know i'll
leave that for you guys to experience
for yourselves but yes
ost and art book
next up on the list
oh
this is the piece de la register this is
the
the steel titan from the game and
my lord that is a lot of parts
this thing is going to be
this thing was going to take a while to
build
so obviously the stacks are like gun
plus decks so you guys can get clippers
and everything to properly clean them
all out and attach them properly and
yeah these are all the parts we have
and i'm trying to find i'm trying to see
if there's like a booklet or something
yeah okay
so instructions are down here the decals
are here as well so this is a very
comprehensive c edition
damn okay so that's um
so let's just put everything together
and i'll give you guys my final thoughts
so all in all it is a very comprehensive
package if you guys are fans of the game
you guys will not be disappointed at all
we have a lot of stuff so let's just
round everything up again so we got
stickers we got a board game we got the
main game we got the ost
with the art book
we got a figurine we got the bag all
with the lifeline branding and this is a
ce that you guys would not want to miss
if you're a big fan so yeah that's all
we have for this video make sure to
follow us on all about socials and if
you have any questions leave them in the
comment section down below and i'll do
my best to get to them but if you like
this video leave a like and subscribe to
us it helps us out a lot and we have a
lot of content coming your way so
without further ado i'm going to go play
the out of this game and i'll see
you guys soon take care
[Music]
you